and when you have a guy that just makes
you have a long
night there's another one a bit of an
elbow there to Ty who is shaking up a
little bit he just took out two guys on
that play Craig up forgive me Craig I
love it okay I love it and now Ty and
Brooks have some words with one
another yeah ty not happy about the low
blow there looks like he got him in the
man Parts I didn't see a windup it looks
like he was just running through the
play got to get a better look the
officials are going to look at this
perhaps do we have our first flagrant
for Dylan Brooks of the preseason I love
it I love it get it out the way I don't
know if they count do the flagrance they
count do they add up get them all get
out get out the way right but that's
backto back fouls on him and then again
that one below the
belt and and now the officials will try
to determine whether or not that was
unnecessary and that will determine
whether or not they upgrade this to a
flagrant one or remains a personal but
Ty was not happy future of the NBA those
chat those wimes those Jabari Smith Jor
those those seven foot guards on the
floor man all right here's our crew
chief Mitchell
Irvin after replay review the fou by Den
Brooks has been upgraded to a flagrum
file penry to den Brooks has been
ejected from the game
wow two free throws and the shot clock
set the 24 inbound on 24 free throw line
extended thank you I thought for
sure that it would probably upgraded to
a flavorant one because of the
unnecessary contact but obviously they
also thought it was excessive contact
for Dylan Brooks so his first outing
with the Rockets here in the preseason
is a short-lived one as he was just hit
with a flagrant two and tossed from the
game
obviously it's preseason you love the
work there from Dylan and I mean he's
not going somebody tell him it's
preseason man he is not going to lack
for effort